Mi spiace signora non ho più niente ho
dato via tutto e signora ho capito ma mi
chiede due strade un ombrellone che
siamo ad agosto Bellini Ah ma se la
figlia del Dottor Ferrari Ah Potevi
dirmelo prima Belin già riaccompagna la
ragazza in prima fila va Mettimela
nell'ombrellone quello lì più bello
Cos'è che vuoi lì la password del wi-fi
però me la chiedete in continuazione
Domani metto un cartello così la
smettete di sfrantumarmi i La
password è qui non si fanno sconti sono
tirchia me ne vado Sì tutto attaccato
tutto maiuscolo giovane se non consumi
al bar no ci può andare in bagno un
caffè
€4,50 Belin signora sua ombrellone hanno
dato quei signori lì ho capito che ha
pagato per tutto il mese ma se lei non
mi si presenta entro mezzogiorno e
glielo devo dare via Mica posso perdere
i soldi Bellini E se non le sta bene
vado da un'altra parte Belin Oh ma robe
da pazzi pagano €3000 al mese
d'ombrellone si lamentano pure sti
milanesi ma statevene a Milano belli